and I found out I was gonna receive this
award they said who do you want to speak
on your behalf
first name out of my mouth already
and I knew it because he's got more
funny stories but when you're a
directory that's not all good because
he's got the damn cast over here telling
them stories and I'm waiting on him I
said ruddy let him up he he let him up
they come over
where's my cut they were back over
listening to ready
thank you thank you so much I appreciate
it you know something you're looking at
the luckiest man alive
and lucky to be alive as a kid folks
didn't think of too much of me and what
I was going to mount to the reason I was
a sharecropper son way back in needles
of Arkansas during the Great Depression
with eight years of education that for
sure for sure my mom is looking to
heaven tonight for the big smile on her
face
so by 1954 I'd serve three years in the
military as a paratrooper any 82nd
Airborne Division where I made over 400
jumps
most of those Oaks are made test and poo
chutes and on a lot of weekends I worked
an aerial thrill show which was perfect
training from my first movie the spirit
the spirit of scentless I started Jimmy
Stewart they were prepared to shoot a
barnstorming sequence all they needed
was two guys to work on top of and
underneath a couple of biplanes the
production manager was talking to my
partner and I about how much we're going
to charge him for the first front hell I
didn't know I'm there done him for I had
no idea what we appropriate but trying
to get as much as that current I said
$2,000 every time we directed a voice
behind me said for $2,000 I'll do it
I'm a drunk it was a director Billy
Wilder he walked past us went down to
the plains climbed up on the top wing
buckle in I said this fools got to be
kidding but he wasn't he motioned the
pilot wounded up and took off
it bounced down across the field made a
couple low passes and landed when Billy
Walter climb down off of that plane he
says he had a twinkle in his eye and a
little smile on his face and he said now
how much
you want we agreed that a thousand
dollars would be just right
I worked six weeks on the spirit when
they paid me more money in this
cotton-picking kid sitting in his life I
now had a decision a goal I was going to
be a Hollywood stuntman when I got into
the business the Senate woodland was
antiquated I know because I broke 56
bones from my back twice punch really
long had a shoulder replaced and knocked
out a few teeth trying to use that stuff
but never believing that in the fact
that that's the way it's always done I
came up with a few pieces of equipment
that made the stunts more real more
active and a lot lot easier safer and
that's really what I was looking for a
way to save my self some trips to the
hospital you know I didn't get here by
myself I had a lot of help a lot of help
and I need to thank some of those folks
like all the stunt men and women who
worked with me and for me and made me
look like I knew what I was doing all
the producers directors and stars that
requested me the Academy Board of
Governors for deciding to give me at
this award this great award and my wife
Ellen for putting up with three for all
these years
nursing me back to health many times but
best of all their never-ending love
honey you're the best
thank you one last thing I want to thank
the entire Hollywood community for
allowing me to be part of it
thank you very much